good afternoon everyone i'm going to get
started so i can get you folks out in
time for lunch
so my talk is about the nim programming
language so what is the nim programming
language so here's just a laundry list
of things that it is um it is a typed
imperative language oh hold on forgot my
speaker nuts it is a typed imperative
language and it's sort of this n-way
love child between like ada
modula oberon pascal
and lisp and it compiles like c c plus
in javascript so
it's got like a nice macro story it's
got a world-class static introspection
story i'm going to get a lot more into
that later
it's got a minimal run time because it
also does static resource management
think of it as more like compile time
rai c plus style
and it also has world class c and c plus
plus interop and yes i mean c plus plus
interop like you know template heavy c
plus plus interop
so i'm going to show you that as well
oh let me go full screen on that
so now that was the what this is the why
why should you care about this language
first of all it looks familiar like you
know the syntactic familiarity is a
cheap marketing trick but it looks
enough like python but i'm just going to
like throw out a bunch of code at you
folks and i'm betting that most of you
are just going to pick it up in context
so i don't have to teach you anything
about this language
and also more importantly it is a very
fast compiler
the compiler the standard library and
the package manager build from c sources
they bootstrap
in about six minutes flat
on this dinky think pad
this is this little five-year-old
thinkpad
so i can stick a debug statement deep
inside the compiler
and i can see that debug statement in my
app code in about 10 seconds
a major nim project the lsp server for
nem that uses the compiler as an api
builds from scratch in about a minute
forget all of the other features aside
if you don't have fast user feedback
none of it matters
i can't really demo fast user feedback
but i think it's important enough to be
like one of the most important things
about him
the second big thing i want to talk
about is static introspection
this is the ability to treat your
compile time environment as metadata
that you can query
i'm going to say that this is a
superpower that nim has
in most other languages types and all
other metadata are locked in and
impossible to access in a programmatic
way
what fields does this record have at
compile time what are they what are
their types
what is the type of an arbitrary
expression and we'll see more examples
of that in a second
the third big reason why you think you
should care is interop specifically with
c plus plus
the key to adoption is interop
typescript scala f sharp
all three of them nice languages
but because they have great interop with
javascript the jvm and the clr they are
now important languages
you wouldn't you wouldn't look at them
twice if they didn't have that
and specifically c plus because c plus
has a ton of useful important and
critical software written in it that
takes a huge amount of access to a huge
amount of effort to access
things like cute
the gui framework tensorflow
many shops cannot get out of c plus
because nothing else can talk to it at
least not without significant effort
imagine zero overhead bindings to
template heavy apis
but first i want to show you a couple of
demos just to show you how easy it is to
get started with this language
here i'm going to have a little web
server example that
takes the url path and capitalizes it
okay so here we go
oh by the way if you can't see that code
please scoot up
so i have some imports
and here i have a handler for the
request that's coming in on this web
server
it's just it's called handle it's a it's
a procedure that's called handle it
takes a request and outputs a feature
none of that really matters except now
we can get it you know it hands you back
a 200 and a message so i can take that
request and i go r dot url dot path dot
split file so this is getting the path
of that url split file splits it into
its various components
dot name dot to
like that and just for grins we can go
ahead and stick this in
a
json blob
okay
and now let's start it
on port
8000
alrighty so let's run that
switch to our terminal
and it returned that json blob
so thrill have some json
yeah thank you
so what i'm hoping is
oops
what i'm hoping is that you agree that
this looks like code that you've seen
before even if i explain nothing about
the language to you you could sort of
like work your way through this and
figure out what it's doing
nothing too surprising here
on the other
end i want to talk about manual memory
management
allocating a bunch of a bunch of strings
and then freeing them
so here we
have our first type in nim it's just an
object and inside of that object is a c
string a c string is nothing more than a
pointer to a bunch of characters a bunch
of null-terminated characters okay
so then we have a function
that does something with that so oops
sorry it takes a number
and that's the number of strings you
have in that array and it allocates
enough space for it
and it goes ahead and creates that
string and allocates some space for that
and copies it into place
this is exactly what you would do in c
no difference
and then
we can make a bunch of those things
so here i'm making 10 strings
and
oops
and i can run through them and for each
one i print it out and then i
de-allocate it at the same time
and then i actually have to de-allocate
the array as well
like so
so when i run that
it's printing out all these strings
and when i val grind it
it's valgrind clean
there's much better ways
of doing memory management in them
but if you need that kind of access you
have it
okay
so what i want what i was hoping to show
you
is that
you can do it
you can learn them it's not that hard
the language has a lot of power and a
lot of like really cool and weird
constructs and i'll get to those in a
sec
but for the most part you don't have to
like sort of change the way you think
about programming just to stuff a json
blob in a web response
right so without really thinking too
hard you can write code that is about
twice as slow as c
which is pretty good for the most part
it has an extensive and diverse standard
library every piece of every demo i'm
going to show you is either going to be
using the language built in or something
in the standard library no package
managers involved
and all of the code is sort of this bog
standard imperative thing that is pretty
familiar looking even inside of the
standard library
okay so on to the fun stuff
oh wait before i do that i want to call
out this really cool syntactic feature
that nim has it's called uniform
function call syntax ufcs and the way it
works is really simple so say you have a
function right it takes a bunch of
arguments and you've got f takes r1 r2
and r3 so the normal way you would call
this function is you would go f and then
open paren r 1 r2 r3 you've seen this
before
what ufcs allows you to do is go arg1
dot f open paren r2 r3
so if this looks weird it shouldn't
because we've already seen this
so when i was doing that server example
that r dot url dot path dot split file
all of this stuff
here split file and two upper ascii are
just plain old functions that happen to
take a path and a string as their first
arguments
so ufcs allows us to just change change
those chain those things along
so you just have plain old functions
there's no need for a language construct
that attaches some kind of like implicit
dictionary to an object
like v tables or type classes
just work with functions
and this is what thomas petrochek of the
university of kent calls dot driven
development
he has a really cool paper called data
exploration through dot driven
development and this is the idea that
you can explore an api just just by
going
thing.thing.thing.thing all the way down
he's got a whole paper on this
so your id can really help you explore
the environment when you have that kind
of facility and although
nem doesn't go as far as f sharp with
that i think ufcs is very much within
the spirit of that and it's a very
simple syntactic transformation
very easy to do in the compiler
and has
a lot of a lot of consequences punches
way above its weight class in my opinion
okay so cool
on to the fun stuff
so what is static introspection
static introspection means that most of
the nim programming language is
available to you at compile time
so here in the static block i have an
echo hello world
what that means is when i compile this
the compiler spits out the string
hello world
and most of the standard library is also
available so in this static block i am
mapping over this hello world list and
capitalizing everything so map and two
upper ascii
these are standard library functions
and it prints out hello world and caps
so the way that does this is not magic i
mean and so how it does this isn't in
addition to having a c back end there's
also this like register based
interpreter back back-end that
understands some subset of the language
and the compile-time constructs are run
inside of that interpreter there's no
magic here
you can also ask whether some arbitrary
expression compiles
at compile time
so this is asking the question
does the expression
oneplus 1.0 even compile
and split that out at compile time
does the expression oneplus slow world
compile spit that out at compile time so
it's spinning out true and false
respectively
and it works with inside of your current
type environment
so here i have a type which is a tuple
by the way tuple and nim doesn't mean
what tuple means and literally every
other language in the universe i don't
know why people do this but
a tuple in them is just an anonymous map
it's just an anonymous record so this is
a record that has an i field and s field
of type intent string
so at compile time i'm instantiating
that with one and blah and i'm asking
hey
does the
does the zero that does o.s.2
upper ascii compile
so it understands that there's this like
type in the environment like this o type
it says true
you can also get the type of something
directly
so at compile time this is asking what
is the type of
this arbitrary expression
and it'll split out float
because you know it's get coerced the
float when you add
and you can use that in place of a type
this isn't just a string so here i have
a function f that takes an end i and i
have a let here x and here the let is
compile time reflecting on the type of
the argument that was passed in and
using that as a stand-in for a type
annotation
so this is exactly like saying let x
call an int except i'm reflecting
instead
and i also want to convince you that the
types are not are calculated not
extracted so there isn't some cheesy
like thing where it goes through the ast
and finds the type signature and grabs
like you know that part of the type
signature and like hands it off d or
something like that no this is actually
calculated so here in this type of i
have a block a block is just an
anonymous scope
and i have a function i have an identity
function so that capital t is a generic
is a generic parameter so it's taking
that generic parameter and just putting
it back out
so when i call identity on two upper
ascii blah
at compile time it is calculating the
type of that expression
is string
so what do we do with all
this so imagine you're a job interview
and they say fizzbuzz
and you're like
yes sure i can do that
and the interviewer interviewer goes
that's great but can you make it faster
and you're like when do i start
because if you for folks that can't see
in the back like adding that compile
time fragment to a function uh makes it
so it runs at compile time so all of
that fizzbuzz stuff is happening at
compile time
so it's faster than doing it runtime and
you get the job
okay that was cheap that was really
cheap i'm sorry
i
that's almost beneath me almost
so anyway a
more a more serious use case is a
problem that i've encountered in every
job that i've done so far
this is the idea that you have a type
and you but you need to migrate that
type over time as things change you need
to diff types and migrate them so here's
an example say you're greenfielding a
project right and you need to model a
person
and you're trying to do it in the
quickest way possible so you have first
name and last name and an age okay cool
and then time passes
and then you add a middle name and you
add an address
and then more time passes and we're up
to today
we've gotten a little more precise with
our types
our age is now a natural number
and our address is now this you know
sort of more structured thing that has
like a street and a city and all of this
stuff
all right beautiful
what is your migration story
how do you get from that first initial
that first initial type
to the second thing with the with the
middle name and the address
to the third thing with the more refined
types
first of all why should you care about
this
you're saying hey i have a web client i
can force an upgrade on clients that
doesn't matter
so what if at some point in the past you
provided a sort of a curl upload
download feature for your rest api that
allowed them to upload and download like
person data
right why did you do this because some
customer who's paying you a lot of money
decided they would rather work with your
personal data in excel
then then in a web gui
and they're not wrong
nothing wrong with that
so you so now that customer takes an
upgrade
they try to upload a csv from an old
version and it breaks
this happens all the time
i
i
suspect it happens in a bunch of your
code bases as well so what do we do
the first thing we can do is embrace the
boilerplate
keep copies of the old types around
right manually write that tedious code
that passes common fields through from
version 1 to version 2 to version n
from experience i know that this
approach is unsustainable and more
importantly its false simplicity
this quickly becomes one of the worst
parts of your code base
no one wants to work on this because
it's soul sucking and it's tedious your
backlog fills up with migration tickets
we in the business call those good first
issues for people on board
or
let's say you have a language that shall
we say has an expressive type system
then you bring in an expert
who writes a framework
that's five layers of abstraction above
the term level
right and now you've traded the problem
of no one wants to work on a migration
do no one can
or like that one person can
at this point you start having these
intrusive thoughts like maybe you should
just use the dynamic programming
language you know like
or
static introspection thrill of this demo
okay so here we have
something that looks like that first
type that i talked about the first name
and last name and the version one of
that with the first name and middle name
and an address
so i wrote
a macro
that diffs
those two types at compile time so it
pulls apart the first type it pulls
apart the second type and it hands you
back a type that is the difference
between those two things
so how does this work so let's run this
and that's what it's handing you
it's handing you back an anonymous tuple
this is a type by the way not a runtime
value an anonymous tuple with two fields
a middle name and an address both of
which are type string
now
let's join up some data got a person
first name last name
okay
now you can
write a migrator
and this migrator compile time reflects
on that diff type
on the difference between those two
types
which is a tuple of a middle name and an
address and it has to provide default
values for those two things
okay cool
now
i wrote another macro
called migrate
that takes some data that original p
namely
name face
and a type that you want to migrate it
to
you want to migrate
to version one
and a migrator
and combines the two things together
so when i echo it
that's what i got
i get the first name but i also get the
middle one i also get the middle name
and i also get the address
okay so let's make things a little more
interesting
okay
and here we have a second type so this
is sort of looks like the more refined
type from today we have an address and
the address is more structured type
which is which has like a street of city
and all of that stuff so what does the
diff type for that look like
so let's run that
and now we have something a little more
interesting
because now you can't just fill in the
default value because think about what
we had before we had an address that was
of type string now we have an address
that is of type address so you can't
when you migrate this thing this macro
is smart enough to go okay you can't
just give me a default value you have to
give me a transformation that's a
function that's an anonymous function
that takes the old value and splits out
something of the new value
and so use get started writing your
migration
so i have a person2 migrate that
reflects on that div type between
version one and version two and now i
have to write a function that does that
migration
and it fills in the address with
this will suck and it will like i hope
you're never in the position of having
to take an arbitrary string and
parse.net and parse aside a legitimate
address from that ever
uh
ever like
break out your parser combinator
libraries or regular expression
libraries like
but in any case
if you want to keep your migration
honest you have to do this
so when i run this and and here i
migrate from person one to person
version two and all this stuff so when i
run this
now i get the first name the last name
and the address
so here we have a principal migration
from one step to another to another so
if somebody ever uploads a csv from an
old version they can always be migrated
to the new version in some way
so i think that
the takeaway here is that if you have a
great serial serialization
deserialization story but no migration
story you have at best solved half the
problem
and also being able to print and take
apart and reassemble like static
structures is absolutely critical and
most type code in my opinion is more
complex than it needs to be because it
does not have a static introspection
story
and thirdly it's just fun you're doing
this like brett victor's style direct
manipulation of static constructs
and that's just cool
so now i want to talk about static
resource management
so first let's always make it let's as
always make a type
so in this case by the way a lot of
these will mirror that first thing i
showed you where we're just putting
putting a bunch of strings inside of the
list so here i have an object that ramps
a sequence of strings there's this is
just native nimcode
there's nothing there's nothing wonky
going on here there's no allocation
there's no like you know like pointers
to characters or anything like that this
is just nativenet
and we have a function
that that does something with it so this
function make o takes an int
and it just kind of uses a for loop to
add a bunch of strings to that to that
sequence and splits it back out
and then we have a function that can
print it
this one just makes one of those o
objects and iterates through it with a
for loop and prints it out very simple
like bog standard stuff
and we have a main function
that can run all this stuff so when i
run this
oh i didn't mean to do that yeah that
was a secret i should not have showed
you that yet
so when i run this it's printing out
it's running all the stuff it's just
printing out you know string indexes
from zero to nine now if i val grind
this
it's val grinding queen
right there's no leftover memory so
somewhere in here nem is implicitly
cleaning up after itself
so where is that happening
well
nim has what's called a destructor hook
this is a destroy hook this is just like
a destructor in c plus
and you can override it and this is how
you do that this equals destroy is a
special function and then that means
like destroy the argument that you know
that comes in that it's parameterized
with
so here all i'm doing is saying destroy
the thing but you know debug something
to to stand it out first
so when i run this
so now after the last use here where it
prints
where it prints it's destroying it
before the after
before the after yeah
right
so
let's see what happens now
if we return
instead of just printing it out we also
return it
[Music]
and we print out the strings inside of
it
when we run that
we see that
destruction doesn't happen until the
last use
so somewhere in there nemo's statically
like tracking all these resources and
figuring things out
so nim statically injects
destructors
after its last statically you know
tracked use
it's like our aii and c plus but it's
completely unobtrusive you can just kind
of forget that this thing exists
also somewhat surprising that most
people don't know about
is that nim has basic rudimentary linear
types
this doesn't advertise anywhere in the
manual
but it it actually does and i think it
illustrates some key philosophies in nim
design
let me show you that
so back to our
string array example
okay
so
let's make a print function
that has a sink
sync indicates that this is a linear
type that is consumed by this function
what that means is that if you call
print sync with some object o that
object o is now consumed and statically
not available for use anywhere else
so what this means is that
this is saying that you can only use o
once or actually it's an affine type you
have to use it
at most once
not exactly once
so what we can do is we can say
make o here and then we can call print
sync
on that o and see what happens
okay let's run this
okay
what's wrong who sees what's wrong
anybody
huh
yes sir all done it's destroyed twice
so it's destroyed after the first time
it's printing
as destroying again after the second
time
if i valgrind this
oops let's
parameterize it with something
look at how much more memory it's using
it's almost double
something's going on
so i could so at this point you're like
i guess linear types are just broken
in them like this feature sucks right
are you asking what is a linear type
so linear type is a a type that you a
linear type is a type that can only be
used once or has to be used exactly once
so this is actually an affine type which
means it has to be used at most once
that means it shouldn't be available
after you use it once yes
so i could tell you the answer to this i
know the answer to this but i'd rather
just show you and this i think
illustrates something cool about nem so
nem has this command line argument
called expand arc
that statically
shows you what the intermediate code
looks like after all the destructors and
copies and copies have been added to it
after it statically tracked all the
stuff and added that stuff this is
this is valid nim code this is what the
compiler sees
and the problem
is right there
so nim goes okay cool i know that i'm
supposed to consume this
you've used it after i've consumed it
i'm just going to i'm just going to go
copy it
this is deliberate this is a deliberate
design decision
and what it illustrates in my opinion is
one of the first philosophies of nymph
is to get out of the user's way
when there is a choice between copying
and bugging the user with some kind of
error
nim just goes ahead and copies
think about the far reaching
far-reaching consequences consequences
that has for the standard library and
all of nemcode you can just write nimco
and forget about the fact that it's
doing the stuff behind the scenes for
you
it's not bugging you with an error
it's just letting you write code
and the second big thing is this
philosophy of show don't tell or
you know that's what expand art does
expand art is showing you exactly what
the compiler sees
and people have used that facility
to spot bugs in the compiler itself
that's far more powerful and better than
some error message in my opinion
so by the way we have control over this
what we can do is
we can disable copying
and the way you do that is just
attaching an error pragma
to the copy hook
and when you do that
now you get an honest to goodness error
that says
there's no copy available for this type
because there's another read
on line 35 and if i go to line 35 that
points to the last thing
so now we've recovered the behavior that
we want if that's the behavior that we
want
so static resources resource management
and nim it works well all of the
standard library and most nim packages
have moved to it and they get a nice
little speed boost from it
and the idea is just relax just just
write some code most of the time it'll
be fine
when you need it profile and then
optimize
and you have complete control over
whether whether copies happen how
destruction happens how a bunch of stuff
happens
but for the most part you don't have to
think about it
so for my last little piece i want to
talk about c plus plus interrupt and i'm
going to show you how to reuse the
standard template library of c plus plus
and here we're going to add a bunch of
strings to stood vector stood vector is
a standard c plus thing
so here we go
so
the first thing we do is figure out how
to map a nim type to a c plus plus type
this is pretty cool so you have a
nimtype called studvector it's
parameterized on some generic t
this maps at code gentime to this string
stood vector with this quote zero inside
of those angle brackets and what the
code zero does is grab
that generic argument and just splice it
in place
so if you weren't stood vector angle
bracket you know stood unique point or
whatever the thing inside of that that
thing that you parameterize it with is
just spliced into place
so we have a stud vector
we have a unique pointer also similarly
parameterized and we have a stud string
that's all it takes to map
a nim type to a c plus plus type
and then we can define some operations
on
the vector
so here we have a vector constructor
and the vector constructor similarly
takes that quote zero it just splices in
that argument and it's an empty
constructor because we're initializing
an empty vector
and then we use
the m place back function from the c
plus plus standard template library and
we add the thing that we're passing in
so this pretty much sort of compiles to
something that looks like
that t that you passed in over here
the at means the rest of the arguments
inside of that function
and
you can use get index and here it's
using a different piece of syntax those
hashes
refer to respectively the first and
second arguments passed in
so this
actually cogens something that looks
like the
five or whatever idx that you passed in
over here
something like that
so we have similar things that we can do
with
a unique pointer
and
a stud pointer
so now we can do some cool stuff with
this we can make a function
oops let me do that
we can make a function that uses all
this so this function takes in the gnome
it's an in how many how many strings am
i allocating and it produces a stood
vector of the stood pointer of a stood
string all in memtypes
so here we make a vector and then we
just iterate through that we just use a
for loop
and create a c-string and add it
using the functions that we just created
so
let's make
like 10 of these things i guess that
should be num oops whatever
and let's run through
so here it's using nim functions
getting the vector getting the index
getting the inner thing inside of that
unique pointer and then getting the
string out of the stud string
and when i run this
it should just print out string at index
0 through 9
and we don't have to worry about memory
here
because the c plus standard template
library vectors and unique pointers take
care of themselves their destructors
destruct the thing that they point to
so if i run this through valgrind
it should valgrind clean that's actually
a fair number of allocations
not sure why it does that
but it's clean
cool
and the last thing i want to show you i
guess i have time for this last thing i
want to show you this thing is really
cool
uh this is a factorial at compile time
okay so this is just a fun like example
of like the kind of interrupt that you
can do between n and c plus plus so here
by the way this is an emit pragma and
the mid fragment means that just take
whatever's inside of those curly braces
and just splice it into code gen like
right there so this like all of the c
plus plus gets slight just just gets
bolted in right there
and what the c plus plus is doing is it
it's using this like recursive template
trick so this is like an old trick you
can find it on wikipedia and all this
this was one of the first examples that
they found that c plus plus templates
are actually touring complete
and like the world has never been the
same ever since you know like people do
crazy stuff with c plus plus templates
now um
yeah
yeah it's nuts but okay so what this
does is it inlines so if you
parameterize it with the static string
and a static number like five it will in
line 5 times 4 times 3 times 2 times 1
and the compiler will sort of golf that
into a constant so this is a compile
time factorial in c plus plus
okay cool
how do we use that from nim
right so that's what this is about like
this is an old trick the new trick is
how you how we bind to this stuff
so here we have a type
uh this type is just like the stood
vector thing uh it has this like you
know quote o thing over there
but instead of taking a t or like an int
or a string or whatever it's taking a
static ant this is like
type level numbers and strings and
things like that in haskell if you're if
you're familiar with that kind of thing
cool so we can parameterize it with a
number 10 or 5 or what have you
and how do you get the value back out
well
it uses this thing called a type desk a
type desk is a meta type
it is a type
that witnesses another type
right so it's like how in it
it's like how it's like in haskell we
have like a proxy where a term witness
is a type and here we have a kind
witnessing a type you know this kind of
thing uh so if you know what that means
it doesn't matter all that matters is
you can carry a type level number inside
of that construct and hand it off to c
plus plus
so when this code gets generated it
looks something like
uh something i don't know something like
that
like three
you know like
it looks something like that when it
generates the code in the end
so here i can
take factorial 3 plus factorial 3.
those will be calculated at compile time
and it gives me back 12.
3 times 2 times 1
plus 3 times 2 times 1.
anyway
so that was just a fun little party
trick
so anywho what c plus plus interop does
is now any c plus plus library is easily
accessible from them your ecosystem just
got orders of magnitude bigger
and trying out nema c plus plus shop is
now a low risk gamble
it's not no risk but it's very low
so to wrap up
first things first a fast compiler
changes the game if you have two equal
languages one with a fast feedback and
one with slow feedback what you have are
two different languages
and i think
without that all of this other stuff
doesn't really
mean all that much
i think that static introspection gives
you the level of dynamism and
flexibility that you get in very few
other languages
and when you need it nothing else will
do i can't think of a better way of
doing that type migration stuff that i
showed you earlier
i can think of worse ways of doing it
but i can't think of a better way
and you get all the benefits of static
memory management but it mostly gets out
of your way and just lets you write code
without worrying about it but the
control is there if you need it
and c plus interop makes nem a viable
alternative in places where almost no
other language would work
plus it increases the size of your
ecosystem many fold
so that's my talk thank you for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you